>> Tucker: THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA SIGNED A BILL BANNING
TEACHERS FROM TALKING TO SMALL
CHILDREN FROM KINDERGARTEN TO
THIRD GRADE ABOUT THEIR OWN OR
ENCOURAGING TO CHANGE THEIR
GENDER.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS INCLUDING DEMOCRATS
AGREE WITH THAT BECAUSE IT IS
COMMON SENSE.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS DISGUSTING
AND A PROBABLY ILLEGAL.
BUT IF THE WALT DISNEY
CORPORATION, THEY WERE
INFURIATED BY THIS.
CALLED AN ALL-HANDS MEETING
DISCUSSING UAS TO DISCUSS
INDOCTRINATING CHILDREN.
CHRIS RUFO OBTAINED FOOTAGE OF
THIS.
HERE IS
INJECTING QUEERNESS INTO MANY
THINGS AS THEY CAN.
>> I DON'T HAVE TO BE AFRAID TO,
LIKE, LET'S HAVE THESE TWO
CHARACTERS CASE IN THE
BACKGROUND.
WHEREVER I COULD, JUST BASICALLY
ADDING QUEERNESS...
IF YOU SEE ANYTHING QUEER IN THE
SHOW...
NO ONE WAS STOPPING ME AND NO
ONE WAS TRYING TO STOP ME!
>> Tucker: OKAY.
HERE IS DISNEY'S DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION MANAGER THAT THE
COMPANY WILL NO LONGER USE THE
WORD "BOYS AND GIRLS."
WATCH.
>> LAST SUMMER WE REMOVED ALL OF
THE GENDER GREETINGS IN
RELATIONSHIP TO OUR SKILLS BUT
WE NO LONGER SAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, BOYS & GIRLS CLUB.
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING TRAINING TO
ALL OF OUR CAST MEMBERS AND IN
THE RELATIONSHIP TO THAT, THEY
NOW KNOW IT'S, HELLO, EVERYONE,
OR HELLO FRIENDS.
>> Tucker: D GENDER
DEGENDERING YOUR CHILDREN.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN US
TONIGHT.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
WHAT EXACTLY WAS THAT?
>> THIS IS AN ALL-HANDS MEETING
IN RESPONSE TO
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS' LEGISLATION
WHERE DISNEY ASSEMBLED THERE
LGBTQ I ACTIVISTS THEY'VE SET UP
IN THE COMPANY AND THEY SAID
THEY ARE DELIBERATELY TRYING TO
TAKE PROGRAMMING THAT GOES FROM
AGES TWO TO SEVEN YEARS OLD TO
INJECT QUEERNESS INTO THE
PROGRAMMING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE ALL OF
THEIR PROGRAMMING'S THESE
LEFT-WING GENDER IDENTITY
COMPATIBLE.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY ARE
FALSELY ACCUSING
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS OF INFO
AND FOMENTING A "DON'T SAY GAY
POLICY" WHICH IS NOT TRUE AT
ALL.
THEY ARE PROJECTING, WE CAUGHT
THEM ON TAPE AND THE EVIDENCE IS
DAMNING.
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE A AGENDA
FOR CHILDREN FOR YOU THINK THAT
WOULD BE ILLEGAL IN SOME WAY.
IT CERTAINLY IMMORAL.
IT'S CREEPY AS HELL.
THEY ARE THE COUNTRY'S LEADER IN
PURVEYING CHILDREN'S PROGRAMMING
QUESTION MIKE THAT THE PROBLEM,
NO?
>> WE CAN SEE INSIDE THE
COMPANY.
EXECUTIVES MADE A DECISION A FEW
YEARS AGO TO MAKE THESE ACTIVIST
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN THE COMPANY
FIRST ON THE ISSUE OF RACE AND
NOW ON THE ISSUE OF GENDER AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
THESE ACTIVIST ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE TAKEN MORE POWER AWAY FROM
THE COMPANY AND THE EXECUTIVES
ARE DOWN LIKE YOU ARE REALLY
COWARDLY AND CRAVEN INDIVIDUALS
CAVE ANYTIME THEY WANT
SOMETHING.
ALL OF THESE VIDEOS, DOCUMENTS,
WHATEVER THESE ACTIVISTS SAY,
THEY ARE NOT CREATING A TRACKING
PROGRAM FOR ALL DISNEY CHILDREN
CONTENT FOR FINDING OUT EXACTLY
HOW MANY TRANSGENDER, ASEXUAL,
BISEXUAL CHARACTERS THEY ARE
PEPPERING INTO THE SHOW EITHER
IN THE FOREGROUND OR BACKGROUND.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A CREEPY BIZARRE
GENDER STUDIES EXPERIMENT ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS BUT IT'S BEING
MAIN LINES INTO CHILDREN'S
PROGRAMMING ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: SOUNDS LIKE THE
BEHAVIOR OF A SEX OFFENDER.
NORMAL PEOPLE DO NOT SEXUALIZE
UNDER AGE CHILDREN PERIOD.
DISNEY DOES NOT FEEL THAT WA